physical strength comes from breaking a
muscle down a thousand times and growing
back a little stronger each time
emotional strength comes from someone's
spirit being broken down a thousand
times and growing back a little stronger
each time the first happens naturally
the second happens by choice if you were
going through it right now think of your
spirit as a muscle and right now you're
working out you're at the gym it's being
torn down and then you can choose to
grow back stronger each time and there
will come a time in the future where
there is no weight or no stress that you
cannot handle because of the amount of
force that you've built in your spirit
thinking through that as every time I
was going through something hard I was
building the muscle rather than thinking
that I was being broken down was one of
the things that got me through my
hardest times